hey you guys welcome to my flickers of
fear show and uh you know for the month
of december we're doing a bunch of sort
of winter themed horror movies and to
that end we are finally finally getting
around to talking about
one of my very very favorite horror
movies of the 1990s actually probably
one of my favorite horror movies of all
time i [ __ ] love this movie and i
kind of feel like
this is another one of those ones that
when it came out back in 1999 i'm pretty
sure like audiences didn't really know
what to make of it because it's a very
odd little movie uh it doesn't really
slot very easily into a single genre
uh so it really did very very badly like
it tanked at the theaters and also it
got a critical drumming as well so i
kind of feel like a lot of people didn't
get it but over the decades uh as a lot
of awesome great movies do it sort of
started to build up a cult following
although i will say that i don't think
the cult following for this one as as
big as it probably should be
considering how [ __ ] brilliant this
movie is and honestly
um if you read a lot about what was
going on behind the scenes of this movie
it's actually kind of incredible that a
movie this good came out of the giant
[ __ ] that was going on behind the
scenes which i'll get into in a bit but
uh so the movie that i'm talking about
today at last is the 1999 film ravenous
now i actually saw this movie when it
came out in theaters back in spring i
think of 1999 i had seen the trailer
which
uh you could tell that the production
this was actually a major studio film i
believe it was fox you could tell that
uh
from the trailer that they really had no
idea how to market this which i get this
is one of those movies that it's kind of
a tough call to say like you know should
we appeal like who should we appeal to
because it has elements of a lot of
different genres in it and stuff that's
like this
particularly because it kind of has a
black humor sensibility to it as well
those are always a hard sell
so i get it but the trailer i'm not
really sure what they were going for
with that i did see the trailer uh when
i was at the movies in the 90s and i was
just you know in early 1999 and i
definitely wanted to see it because one
it's about cannibals and two
robert carlisle is in it and i [ __ ]
love robert carlyle i was like i said
i'm i was really into like british
cinema so i had seen him in a lot of
british films i don't think the full
monty had come out yet at this point but
he'd been a train spotting obviously
so he was kind of like a big name i
can't remember if full monty was before
this or after this but i had seen him in
several movies and you know he's a
scottish actor and uh i [ __ ] love him
so i was just kind of like well i'm
gonna see anything with him in it
because he's always [ __ ] great
so
i went to see this movie in 1999
and i think there was maybe two or three
other people at the theater
and
i don't think they got it at all i saw
the movie and i thought it was great i
thought it was just like gory and fun
and hilarious uh in like a very blackly
humorous kind of way which is right up
my alley but i kind of feel like other
people just kind of like what the [ __ ]
did i just watch like they didn't really
get it because it is a very strange it's
a very tonally strange kind of movie i
almost want to say do you remember like
a couple weeks back when i reviewed that
really weird uh bob balaban movie
parents from 1989 which is also about
cannibals but where it has this kind of
weird like surreal
you know john waters type of thing but
also kind of like horror and it had like
black comedy in it but not overtly funny
this is kind of like that i would call
this movie actually if this isn't too
weird a thing to say maybe parents meets
bone tomahawk you know what i mean so
it's kind of like i think all the three
of those movies would make like a really
good cannibal movie night you know so
just saying that's like a recommendation
if you ever have anybody over that are
really into cannibal movies like weird
blackly comedic uh gruesome cannibal
movies then
i think those three would be a good
triple feature because they
you know other than bone tomahawk which
is more serious you know and parents
which is more surreal this one is almost
kind of like in the middle of those
because it has serious elements to it it
has gruesome elements to it but it's
also funny but again like parents not
overtly funny uh the funny comes more
from
just these very it's very gallows humor
um and it comes more from
just the quirks of the characters rather
than them being like jokes so i wouldn't
necessarily call it a horror comedy it's
sort of like a western
black comedy horror
something you know what i mean it's
really not not categorizable by any
stretch of the imagination
so what ended up happening with this
film uh i guess as i said it's a major
uh you know it's a major studio was
putting it out uh the screenwriter of
this was ted griffin who later on would
do ocean's eleven i believe he also did
matchstick men but this was might have
been his first major studio picture if
i'm not mistaken
now the studio was not super jazzed
about it uh but they were gonna make it
a small budget it ended up costing about
12 million sadly it only made a little
more than two million back so like i
said it was a pretty uh serious flop
unfortunately
but so they had this screenplay now the
original uh direct director that they
had was milcho mancheski i hope i'm
pronouncing that right who i believe is
macedonian and he had just won an oscar
i think for like best foreign language
or something like that
so they gave this to him
he was on the film for like three weeks
and uh it just clearly was not working
out uh the producers weren't loving it
the crew wasn't loving it the actors
weren't loving it it just didn't seem
like a good fit so that director was
fired
uh at which point the studio wanted to
bring in i can't remember the dude's
name but the guy that directed home
alone three
and um
some more like i think big mama's house
maybe like i can't remember but uh some
more kind of big screen like comedy [ __ ]
like that like wacky comedy
um so they were gonna bring that guy in
and all the actors basically said we are
not we are walking off the set of this
[ __ ] movie if you bring that guy in
so robert carlisle the awesome scottish
actor said why don't you hire
antonia byrd now she is a british
director uh she sadly passed away of
cancer in 2013 at the age of 62 sadly
she had made a lot of british dramas and
uh would go on but she this is i think
her only major
uh you know hollywood picture it wasn't
a good experience for her she didn't
love it um so she kind of went back to
britain and did stuff over there but her
and robert carlisle had worked together
before uh in a movie called priest i
think which is actually like really
awesome if you haven't seen it and i
think one called face and so he was a
big fan of their collaborated a lot and
actually i think after this movie came
out i think they actually started a
production company together if i'm not
mistaken
so he suggested that she come in and uh
she agreed to come in and do it uh with
basically only a week to prepare so she
was brought in kinda last minute so like
i said considering that she was brought
in that she was the third director
that was brought in like at the
absolute last minute it's amazing that
this movie turned out as awesome as it
turned out also have to point out the
cinematographer uh the same
guy that did a lot of uh nicholas roix
movies he did don't look now i think he
did man who fell to earth uh so the
cinematography looks fantastic it's
supposed to be set in the sierra
nevada's i believe they shot it in
mexico and i believe in eastern europe
somewhere uh maybe the czech republic
but it actually does look like the
sierra nevadas all these snowy mountains
and it's really you can really tell
because you know how sometimes when they
do movies and it's supposed to be winter
time and the actors like they're not
even they don't even look cold you know
what i mean like their breath isn't even
you know they're they don't even have
like uh you know the breath puffs coming
out or anything like that this movie
looks
wet and cold and miserable and dirty and
so it really lends a lot to uh to the
kind of atmosphere of this film because
it looks like it was really [ __ ] cold
there and nobody was having that good a
time
so uh this movie has an all-star [ __ ]
cast not only do you have robert carlyle
you guys have uh guy pierce uh jeffrey
jones david arquette there's just like
so many great actors in this so the
story of this was based loosely
on kind of like donner party uh kind of
stuff also a little bit on alfred packer
who i believe we did a the colorado
cannibal i think we did a show about him
not too long ago i think when we were
doing like one of those old west or like
cannibals of the old west type of show
but we did talk about him and this is
kind of loosely based on that
so this is set in 1847 during the
mexican american war
now john boyd who's played by guy pierce
uh he is a second lieutenant at the
beginning
now he's in this battle
and uh he actually kind of like chickens
out like in the middle of his battle
because all of his like the dudes in his
regiment are getting like shot left and
right in this battle and they're losing
so he starts getting scared so he
pretends what he's so he just pretends
to be dead uh so that he doesn't have to
fight anymore
now as it happens um because he plays
dead like the mexican army kind of
gathers all the bodies up and so he ends
up underneath this big pile of his dead
uh comrades
and uh taken back to
the army camp like the mexican army camp
now on the way there since he's
underneath all these dead bodies he's
basically drinking in the blood of like
his commanding officer
which uh is implied later on actually
gave him the strength to
climb out of you know underneath all
these bodies and take out the whole
entire like mexican army regiment like
single-handedly
so
because so at the beginning like he's
actually given a commendation and he's
given a promotion to captain
but because his commanding officer knew
that the only reason that he was able to
take out that whole regimen was because
he
you know chickened out and played dead
you know it was an act of cowardice so
they're like well you know for
you know publicity's sake we'll have to
like you know make you a war hero blah
blah but we know that you only did it
because you were
being a weenie so
they actually send him to this remote
outpost fort spencer out in the sierra
nevada mountains in california where
they kind of send all of their
misfits and losers you know what i mean
so i've seen several uh reviews of this
they called it like the island of misfit
toys it's essentially like that so fort
spencer once he gets out there uh has
kind of a little ragtag
uh team of people that uh that are there
it's under the command of colonel hart
uh who's played by jeffrey jones and
he's kind of just like you know like
he's an older kind of chill type of dude
and he's just like whatever you know
we're just out here i'm just out here
reading my books and nothing ever
happens it's you know it's fine so he's
just gonna like stay out there and
collect his pension or whatever
uh you also have private toffler who is
like the you know he's the religious guy
like the little priest or whatever
private cleaves uh who is just basically
a giggling drug addict uh you know
smoking the peyote and all that kind of
stuff you also have major knox who is
uh who was a veterinarian in his former
life so he kind of serves as the like
camps or sats doctor but he is also a
hopeless drunk and is pretty much drunk
all the time
uh you also have private reich who is
who i think it's funny that they called
him that because he's kind of like uh
the blonde aryan superman like he's like
super soldier but he's also kind of like
psychotic he's got like these bright
like blue like crazy eyes and [ __ ] like
that and he's just like very you know
what i mean he's that type of dude
and then there is a brother and sister a
native american who are just kind of
like general crew around the place uh
their names are george and martha so
boyd gets there he's kind of introduced
to all these you know quirky individual
people
and not too long after that a stranger
turns up at fort spencer in the form of
robert carlisle
calling himself calhoun now he kind of
falls he looks like he's starving and
he's frozen and all this other stuff so
of course they bring him in to help him
out and as soon as he recovers uh he
tells them the horrifying story
of uh him and a party of five other
people
who were uh trying to basically do a
wagon train through the sierra nevadas
the leader of this group was a dude
named colonel ives who said that he had
this shortcut through the mountains uh
but it was actually much longer they
ended up getting trapped uh in the
mountains in the winter and ended up in
this cave where spoiler alert they all
ended up pretty much having to eat one
another so at this stage um calhoun
admits that he uh ate you know some of
the
some of the people that were dead uh
because he said you know we ate the ox
and we ate the horses we had our shoes
we had our belts uh you know and then
finally you know one of the one of the
other settlers like died of starvation
so we ended up having to eat him and i'm
not proud of it but that's just what
happened he's like but colonel ives uh
who was the leader of the thing once he
tasted human flesh he started acting
like a savage and ended up murdering
like the other members of the party at
which point calhoun says that he just
like got the [ __ ] out of dodge even
though he said oh i feel bad because i
left colonel lives there with the one
woman that was in the party um you know
but i just couldn't take it anymore so i
had to leave and this is you know where
i turned up now uh while he's telling
this story george one of the uh did one
of the native american uh know people
that lives on the on at the settlement
he's like looking really scance at this
guy because obviously uh most people
nowadays know i feel like it was less uh
widely known like mythology back in 1999
when this movie came out but now there's
been several movies like antlers and
stuff like that that are about the
wendigo or
wendigo as they say in this movie which
is actually i think more correct
pronunciation if i'm not mistaken
uh so he's basically like okay well a
dude that eats another man's flesh uh
sometimes will become sort of possessed
by you know the wendigo demon and they
just keep eating and eating and eating
and they never get enough and that's you
know they they just become savages
essentially so he's kind of like worried
about this dude obviously no one really
no none of the you know white settlers
the white people at the camp really care
that much about that there's basically
like okay well you left this woman in
this cave with colonel ives and maybe
he's gonna eat her so
you know uh colonel hart is like well
you know this is our job we have to go
and save her we have to go like see you
know we have to send out a rescue
mission
so that's what they do so they they hike
for like three days
to try and find this cave that he was
talking about
and they do find it but when they get
there should i go should i say spoiler i
just feel like this movie came out such
a long time ago it came out in 1999 but
i feel like a lot of people maybe
haven't seen it but i will say i don't
know because i think the trailer kind of
spoils it so i guess i don't feel too
bad but so they get to the cave
and uh reich and boyd go in the cave and
they find like a bunch of skeletons and
stuff like that but the way the [ __ ] is
situated they're sitting there going um
hang on didn't he say didn't calhoun say
that you know there was that they ate a
couple of the people but then there was
two left that were still alive and it
was colonel ives it was doing all this
[ __ ] and then he took off he's like okay
so then why are there five
skeletons like strip goopy skeletons
like stripped of their flesh like
hanging from the ceiling of this cave
and then they realize holy [ __ ] this is
a trap calhoun has led them to this cave
and it's actually uh he was the one that
ate all of the ones so he's actually
it's either he's either colonel ives the
whole time or he took over the bi i kind
of feel like he was probably just
colonel ives the whole time and he just
took on the persona of one of the other
members of the party to make himself
like look more innocent so i think
that's what it is so basically he led
them to this place like as a trap
because he wants to eat them uh so he
ends up killing like a whole bunch of
the members of the party boyd escapes by
jumping off this cliff and like breaking
his leg and he falls into this pit with
reich who you know is killed the thing
about it is that boyd
also has some of this uh human flesh
kind of thing going on too because if
you remember at the very beginning of
the movie
that's how he ended up wiping out that
whole mexican army garrison was because
he you know swallowed the blood and
flesh of like all the bodies that were
on top of him so he essentially also has
the wendigo demon inside him too but
he's been able to resist it even though
it's very difficult for him it's
interesting the way
the way that um antonia byrd portrayed
the wendigo thing it's kind of more she
kind of portrays it like an addiction
you know what i mean or like a disease
which i guess it kind of is
so the so the main moral kind of um
conflict comes from robert carlisle's
character calhoun or colonel ives if you
uh would prefer because that's who he
actually is um who
has embraced uh the wendigo thing and
has embraced cannibalism because it
makes him stronger um he you know healed
he had tuberculosis before and it healed
it and he's just like you know i feel
fantastic so he's kind of like taking it
on board so he's just like i'm down i'm
a cannibal now whereas boyd um he has
tasted human flesh uh and ends up having
to eat parts of reich when he's you know
escaping from
when he's escaping from the cannibal uh
to heal his leg up so he can get back to
the camp and destroy the other cannibal
but he's
you know morally uh you know morally
averse to eating other people
so it's this constant struggle that he
really really wants to eat other people
but you know in a in a drug addict kind
of way but he's just bound and
determined to kind of keep his humanity
so that's kind of where the whole uh
moral conundrum comes from with like
robert carlisle's character and guy
pierce's character
both being cannibals but
you know having but one of them being
like a roleoptic animal so i don't want
to spoil too much about
the way it goes from then on because i
kind of feel like it's best appreciated
just you know letting it play out the
way it's going to play out as i said
this is a very it's a fascinating movie
this is like an odd
wonderful little film and i really do
kind of feel like
it's sad that i mean i you know i say
this a lot because particularly horror i
feel like sometimes stuff comes out
that's maybe kind of like a little bit
ahead of its time or people didn't
really know what to make of it and
as i said even this one audiences didn't
get it and critics didn't really seem to
get it either so it seemed to take a
really long time to find its audience
and i don't think it has as big an
audience as i think it probably should
have because this is actually a pretty
brilliant little movie and it's just so
weird um just the tone of it is kind of
all over the place but it also kind of
works which
you know it's very difficult to blend
genres in this way and still have it be
a successful movie
but
the way that this one is done it's done
in like such an odd like off-kilter kind
of way you don't really see i've never
really seen a movie
that's much like this you know what i
mean and especially not from a major
studio for christ's sake i mean this is
a very very unusual film just
like i said you can't even it's kind of
it's a western period piece type of
thing you know kind of like war movie
type of thing but then it's also you
know really gory and it also has horror
elements to it particularly in robert
carlisle's character who
man for a little bitty dude um you know
he's kind of a you he's like a kind of a
smaller like a wiry kind of fella and uh
but man he is
terrifying in this but also
strangely seductive and really kind of
like funny and so like all of the but
not funny in like an overtly zany kind
of way i mean just the humor in this
just hit me right even when i first saw
this in the theater like back in 1999 i
was just dying i just thought this movie
was
hysterical like not
you know like i said not an over top
zany way but just in that black comedy
kind of way and it's just i love that
kind of strange humor like that and it
just cracked me up and i was like
i was kind of like when i was in the
theater i was like why am i the only one
laughing at this like it's funny but i
don't know if other people thought it
was supposed to be funny even though i
did see some trailers
at the time that kind of tried i saw one
trailer that tried to make it look more
like a slasher movie and then there was
one trailer that kind of made it try to
make it look like a comedy
and it's really neither of those things
um it's just like i said it's all over
the place tonally but
it still works though uh i have to bring
up the score as well uh the score was
actually um it was two british composers
they didn't work together uh they just
independently came up with uh with uh
music for the for the movie uh the first
of these was michael nyman
and uh the other one was damon albarn of
uh blur and gorillaz fame
and uh the score for this
is i kind of see it like uh in the
horror community this is kind of
considered one of the best scores like
horror scores particularly the 90s or
you know just in general but it is also
very weird um
this score is just very very strange
it's kind of has like some banjo kind of
stuff and like during a couple scenes
like there's a there's one chase scene
where
uh where calhoun or colonel ives if you
prefer is chasing boyd like through this
forest uh you know being his all
cannibalistic and stuff and the music is
almost kind of like almost shades into
like this kind of goofy banjo kind of
thing but
it's just one of the oddest horror movie
scores you will ever hear but it's also
kind of awesome and it totally works uh
you wouldn't think that it would this is
one of those movies that like i said if
you talk about all the disparate
elements of it
it's just there's like oh there's no way
that could like work and make a
fantastic movie but it totally does i
don't know how like it all
somehow miraculously all came together
into this awesome like wonderful
fantastic
cannibal movie but
it totally works like every
every actor in it every just it's just
so quirky and weird and i [ __ ] love
every second of it also uh you can read
it in a lot of different ways too like i
said black comedy um you know there's a
lot of gallows humor in it it's also
kind of a parody or a satire of the idea
of manifest destiny uh or you know the
the western expansion where it's sort of
making the
comparison of
you know robert carlisle's character
colonel ives who is planning to
essentially set up a cannibal outpost so
all of the people that are coming into
california like during you know when
they're coming looking for gold or
whatever he's going to like eat some of
them
so it's kind of like uh making a
comparison between you know manifest
destiny colonialism stuff like that with
cannibalism where it's just kind of like
you know they're just eating everything
they're eating all the resources so it
kind of makes that it's not super
heavy-handed yeah i don't think but it's
there if you want to take it uh there's
also a very very large uh homoerotic
type of uh thing to it again not super
overt uh and it's kind of done very
cheekily uh but it totally is in there
and even um even robert carlisle said
even we were working on the movie uh you
know some of the scenes were just like
you know just kiss him already you know
what i mean because it's kind of
equating
cannibalism with
uh you know it's kind of this virility
masculinity you know kind of a
homoerotic sort of uh subtext to it but
like i said done in a very cheeky
kind of like funny kind of way you know
what i mean like this sort of sardonic
uh kind of look at it
so that's also in there if you want to
uh take it as well but again this is
just a fun
you know i i just have a lot of fun with
this and every single time i've seen it
because i've seen it several times and i
think i i actually had on a dvd
so i've seen it several times since i
first saw it in the theater and i just
every single time i see it
i just love it even more like every
i just find something else in it like
something new to love about it uh so and
i think that's like the hallmark of the
best movies and it just makes me sad
that this isn't
a better known film it's not for
everybody obviously but
if you like uh kind of western style
stuff like i said if you like bone
tomahawk uh this is
tonally
not exactly like that but it's kind of
along the same lines
but also kind of mixed with this subtle
like kind of sardonic black comedy and
it's pretty gory i don't know if i'd
call it as i don't know if it's as gory
as bone tama although bone tomahawk i
feel like that's mostly just that one
scene like that one scene that everybody
talked about which is
legit one of the most disgusting things
i've ever seen uh this one
has a lot of gore in it and you know it
has a lot of kind of you know broken
legs and
[ __ ] like that so it's very very bloody
and very gory but i don't know if it's
as violent i don't know it but it is
like pretty gory so if you like gory
stuff and you know and you like like a
lot of
kind of blackly humorous stuff about
eating other people then this should be
right up your alley it's definitely one
of the most best cannibal movies ever
made uh definitely one of the best
wendigo movies ever made and honestly
like i said this is
this came out in 1999 which was before i
feel like the wendigo myth was really
that
you know well-known in american culture
i kind of feel like like i said lately
there's been more movies with using that
mythology but not so much like back when
this came out i feel like it was kind of
a real original concept for 19.99 and
it's just a shame that it seemed like it
didn't really find an audience uh until
much later on
and uh oh i will mention too that
antonia bird
she had always this came out kind of the
way she wanted it but she had always
like meant to uh recut it because she
said you know you know like i said she
didn't really like she was british and
she didn't really like uh working with
major hollywood studios she thought it
was you know just a [ __ ] and she
couldn't take it and uh because they
just kept meddling and everything and so
they re-cut the movie in some ways that
she wasn't real happy about so she
always kind of wanted to like recut the
movie but sadly as i said she passed
away in 2013 and she never got a chance
to one of the things she didn't like was
that uh and i don't i'm not a big fan of
this either uh it doesn't ruin the movie
or anything because just like a second
but at the very beginning of the movie
it starts with uh with a quote like the
nietzsche quote you know the one about
uh you know in fighting monsters don't
become a monster blah blah and then
underneath it it says you know it says
quote eat me anonymous which funny
because it's a cannibal movie but
i kind of feel like that
that sense of humor is not the same
sense of humor that's on display
in the movie you know what i mean uh it
seems like you can tell this was a
british director because it has like a
very british
dry
humor to it which i really like um but i
guess a lot of american audiences didn't
weren't down with it like especially
back in 1999 they didn't really get it
or they didn't know why it was supposed
to be funny because like i said it's not
jokes it's just like some of the
situations or some of the character
quirks are funny um you know
situationally funny and like i said the
you know the lines are just very dry
and that's what's funny about them i
guess it's like hard to explain but it
is a much more like british humor than
american humor i guess but yeah so she
didn't really like um that quote thing
at the beginning because she said that
just seemed kind of stupid and uh you
know again it doesn't really match the
humor of the rest of the film and she
also made the point she's like well i
kind of feel like a lot of hollywood
studios think their audiences are stupid
uh but they're not it's so it's almost
kind of like they had to put that
they're like hey it's supposed to be
funny and she's like yeah we didn't
really need that but whatever uh like i
said it doesn't ruin the movie or
anything it's just like a second but you
know you could
totally trim that off and it would be
completely fine which was one of the
things she wanted to do but yeah if you
have not seen
ravenous from 1999 please check it out
um it is just one of the most criminally
underrated horror films of all time uh
and it's just so great like just the
cast the ensemble cast is so good robert
carlisle is amazing in it and it's just
so fun and funny and just
i don't know it's just so odd that
it's just it just warms my heart like
every time i see it that a movie this
weird
was made by a major studio even though
it didn't do very well
um i'm just kind of like it just makes
me so happy that uh that this movie
exists because i just [ __ ] love it so
much and like i said it's one of my
favorite easily one of my favorite
horror movies from the 1990s which like
i said probably my least favorite decade
for horror movies but a lot of good ones
did come out during that time period and
this is easily one of them so please
check it out um i actually watched it on
uh amazon prime uh you can't get it for
free i think you have to rent it but
it's only 3.99 and it's totally worth it
and you know it's worth more than that
too but i think you can run it on
youtube for the same price so you can
see in a lot of uh streaming services so
please check it out or if you've seen it
if you're uh part of the cult of
ravenous one of the people that saw it
when it came out like i did and uh we're
kind of like why why are more people
talking about this movie it's like so
awesome but uh you know so if you've
seen it uh let me know what you thought
of it we'll have a discussion about it
in the comments and that will do it for
this flickers of fear and i will see you
guys on the next one
bye